>> Brian: IT'S MY JUKEBOX, I
DON'T EVEN HAVE CHANGE FOR A
DOLLAR.
WE ARE LOOKING LIVE IN
CINCINNATI, SPLITTING THE SCREEN
WITH THAT LIVE EVENT, JUST OVER
AN HOUR FROM NOW THE PRESIDENT
WILL HOLD A "KEEP AMERICA GREAT"
RALLY.
ABOUT TWO HOURS AGO IN A
POSSIBLE PREVIEW OF HIS SPEECH.
>> I WATCHED ELIZABETH WARREN,
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
POCAHONTAS WITH HER PHONY
ANCESTRY.
EVERYTHING SHE DID WAS A FRAUD,
I THINK KAMALA DID NOT DO WELL
LAST NIGHT, I THINK JOE BIDEN
DID OKAY, HE CAME THROUGH, HE
CAME LIMPING THROUGH, LIMPED
RIGHT THROUGH IT.
IT'S REALLY BOILING DOWN TO FOUR
OR FIVE OF THEM.
>> Brian: WHAT ROLL WILL THE
TONIGHT DEBATE EXTRAVAGANZA HAV
HAVE?
>> Dana: I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WILL PLAY HIS GREATEST HITS BUT
NOT INITIALLY, AT SOME POINT HE
WILL GO THROUGH AND GO DOWN THE
LINE, HE WON'T BE ABLE TO
MENTION ALL 20 OF THEM BUT HE
WILL HIT THE TOP ONE, I THINK
IT'S REALLY SMART TIMING TO
SCHEDULE THIS RALLY ON THE NIGHT
AFTER THE DEBATE, OKAY, YOU'VE
GOT TO FIND KNIGHTS, THREE HOURS
EACH OF THOSE DEMOCRATS AND NOW
THE PRESIDENT WILL COME IN AND
BECAUSE THIS IS A CONTRAST
ELECTION, IT'S A CHOICE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WHOEVER FROM
THAT STAGE OR ELSEWHERE EMERGES
AS A NOMINEE, LOOK AT THE
CONTRAST.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN MICHIGAN,
THEY HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO VOTERS IN MICHIGAN, A
STATE THEY LOST BY AN INCH THAT
THEY DESPERATELY NEED TO WIN
BACK IN 2020.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY CONTRAST IS
GOING TO OHIO, NO REPUBLICAN'S
EVER WON AN ELECTION WITHOUT
OHIO, HE'S LEAVING NOTHING TO
CHANCE.
I BET HE BRINGS VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S COMMENTS, BRING THAT UP
IN OHIO, SEE HOW THAT GOES.
>> Brian: I THINK EVERYONE
AGREED WITHIN TEN YEARS,
ESPECIALLY A PLACE THAT IS RUN
BY THE CAR INDUSTRY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BE
A LITTLE AT A LOSS, NINE PEOPLE
KILLING BARACK OBAMA, THAT'S
WHAT HE WAS DOING.
DOES HE EVEN BOTHER TALKING
ABOUT OBAMACARE BEING BAD?
EVERYONE AGREES IT'S BAD NOW.
>> Juan: HE WAS EMBEDDING HIS
OPINION.
>> Greg: I THINK THEY SHOULD
INITIATE SOME CHANTS.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE TWO WORLD,
ON ONE HAND, PROSPERITY, PEACE,
JOBS AND ON THE OTHER HAND THE
FEDERAL APOCALYPSE AND YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO SEE THE DELUSION THAT IS
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS JUAN HAS IT
SHOWED, THAT MEDIA IS SUFFERING
FROM ORD, OBSESSIVE RACE
DISORDER.
IF HE CRITICIZES ANYBODY OF
COLOR, IT'S OVER.
>> Brian: MEDICARE FOR ALL,
DECRIMINALIZE THE BORDER, IT'S
NOT EVEN AN EXAGGERATION, THAT'S
WHAT WE HEARD FOR THE LAST TWO
PHONE NIGHTS RIGHT?
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT DANA
SAID IS ON TARGET, GET THE
PRESIDENT OUT RIGHT AFTER THE
DEMOCRATS DOMINATED THE AIRWAVES
FOR TWO NIGHTS.
YOU KNOW, I THINK HE'S GOT TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL.
IT DIDN'T HELP HIM, AND TONIGHT,
HE'S NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
NORTH KOREA FIRING MISSILES
AGAIN, NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
FAILING TRADE TALKS WITH CHINA.
I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO GET
ANGRY AT JEROME POWELL, THE
FEDERAL RESERVE CHAIRMAN.
HE'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT ALL HIS
FAILURES, I THINK IT'S MORE
LIKELY HE TRIES TO GO AFTER
JOE BIDEN, POCAHONTAS, YOU KNOW
KNOW --
>> Greg: THOSE ARE TWO WHITE
PEOPLE, JUAN, YOU JUST DISPROVED
YOUR POINT.
>> Emily: 100% HE'S GOING TO
LEAD INTO JOE BIDEN AND EVERYONE
ELSE'S COMMENTS ABOUT PHASING
OUT COAL AND FRACKING, ET CETER
ET CETERA, WE SAW THAT ON
TWITTER, WE TALKED A LITTLE
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS 100%
ALIENATING A LOT OF THOSE VOTERS
WHO HAVE BEEN MAKING THEM SEEM
LIKE THEY ARE PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
I THINK YOU WILL JUMP ON THAT,
TOO.
>> Brian: ONE CHANCE DOMINATED
A 90 MINUTE SPEECH, SO HE'S GOT
TO DO THINGS THAT ARE MAYBE OUT
OF HIS CONTROL.
IF HE HEARS SOME TYPE OF CHANT,
DO YOU NOT STEP BACK, STEP
FORWARD, "WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR
THAT?"
>> Dana: ARE YOU ASKING WHAT
WOULD I DO?
>> Brian: WHAT YOU THINK HE
WOULD DO.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW, I
REALLY DON'T KNOW.
>> Emily: THE SECOND TIME,
AFTER THAT --
>> Dana: THE PEOPLE, I DON'T
KNOW.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE TO SEE.
IT COULD BE THAT NO ONE CHANCE.